so these you guys
are brainwashing these young kids
without giving them any solutions right
yeah and these young a lot of these high
school boys
and a lot of these college guys they
watch these videos and they actually
believe what they're preaching and have
you noticed that all these guys these
black
peop none of them show off their face
correct yeah they and people actually
believe them without
seeing them like
making sense and that's the funny thing
because a lot of these like
guys will
see stuff like my content and they'll
call me a pickup artist or a pua
and and say that i'm a snake oil
salesman
right well where exactly is the snake
oil that i'm selling
where
where have i shown you that but instead
what they're selling is doom and gloom
they're the real snake oil salesman they
they're they're cowards they won't show
their face
right right some of them might argue
that they're not good looking enough and
that's why they don't show it or maybe
they don't want to lose their job but
that just tells me look if you're not
man enough to show your face then don't
bother talking about something because
you're not an expert on it if you're a
coward the the thing that i learned most
is it's better to hold frame and lose
the girl then lose frame and live your
life on your knees or live the
relationship on your knees and i went
through a situation the last couple of
weeks where a girl flaked on me for
dinner
yeah yeah tell that story yeah so i i
cut her off and you know i spoke to a
couple of you guys in the community and
you were like well don't be like
butthurt
ghost her just say cool no problem
so 24 hours later i said cool no problem
and then i just dropped it after that it
went on about my life doing my stuff
because
i learn i if she's not coming into my
frame i'm not going in her frame i'm not
going to chase her blue pilbara me in
the past would have went after her would
have texted her and said hey you want to
come out wednesday instead some nonsense
like that
so i just went on about my life friday i
get this text
and i just message her back and i say
let's talk so we talk
and you know
she says she's really into me and all
that and i said look i just want you to
know i have standards i said i do not
buckle to those standards you flaked on
dinner if you want to go back out with
me you're going to take me out to my
favorite restaurant which was last night
i said you're going to pay for it you're
going to buy me drinks and you're going
to apologize
and i was like a zfg mod i'm like i
don't care you know i said all those
things i never thought i'd say in the in
the past to a girl you're going to
apologize to me you're going to take me
to dinner so you know all that stuff
happened we went out last night we had a
great time and and this is you know one
thing i want to emphasize is holding
frame is not bossing on chicks or
winning or getting one over on them it's
having self respect and i said to moff
earlier if you were if you're a young
guy listening to this this podcast and
you have never walked off the lot from a
used car dealer you won't be able to
whole frame you have to be able to walk
away from something that you like and
like it a lot
if you can't do that frame's gone
yeah what are your thoughts are on a
um you know pop uh phone
scavenging hunt
um i'll give you my experience i am
i'm not gonna ask i think there's
you know i can certainly see that some
guys that it makes a lot of sense and
something they want to do but i think
there's so many other behaviors
that you'll be able to pick up on where
it's like
it's either well it's probably the best
way to put it you'll see another
behavior
where you're like okay this is not
you're
we're clearly two different places here
you know i think where it really comes
into play is you know is this going to
turn into a long-term relationship or
not this is just some
gal you're seeing it's like who cares
but if this has turned into something
more serious
and i agree with steve 100
checking those references if you will
will tell you everything
but
i i don't want to go through some chicks
bone to be honest
i'll tell you guys why i think it's
actually not a bad idea and i agree with
steve because
you know she ended up giving him the
where do we stand talk and he's like
okay fine i'll abandon my sexual
strategy of unlimited access to
unlimited women all right but then the
spidey senses started to tangle and he
wanted to verify for himself and i don't
think that there's anything wrong with
that especially given the conversation
that he had and what his relationship
goals are
right
i'm in the same i'm in the same boat um
you know with my
with my current ltr it's not like
you know every freaking second but once
a month once every two months if i just
happen to see your phone i'll pick it up
scroll through the text
and see if there's anything weird there
because she she's a she does she does
outside sales
and ninety percent of her clients tell
her men
and i know i know what the deal is so
you know yeah and i just and it's not
malicious or anything like that it's
just like
i'm i'm going to make sure
that everything is straight and if it's
not straight it's going to be confronted
immediately this is the deal she knows
that i agree with that and in my opinion
you know i don't
i don't want to to promote an ongoing
culture of mistrust
and kind of the way i couched it in the
moment is
is you know i'm asking for this
because of the following criteria you
and i agreed to there's behaviors xyz
that don't align to this you're telling
me you want something different that you
want a second chance i'm receptive to
that
but i need some currency and coin in the
realm to know that what you're asking
for is legitimate and that i'm not just
getting strong along um and so when she
agreed to that i think that was a it was
it showed heavy investment on her part
that hey i'm willing to open the books
to this guy
i'm willing to show him you know the the
records he's looking for to get that by
in
um you know because again if if
hypergamy's not satisfied or it's
satisfied only in that moment you are
setting yourself up for failure
um but when she in my opinion in that
moment she's willing to open the books
and willing to talk about everything
um that gives me that you know as you
mentioned rich that extra reassurance
okay hey i am the hyperdrama's best
option here she is being genuine in the
thing she's talking about the story
she's telling me about the work life is
is is genuine and there's not the the
social media attention seeking behavior
that i think wrecks a lot of women in
relationship
right on something chad and i talk about
a bunch and i think this is something
that is really permeating the space and
just in general this idea
about
uh they need to be more emotional they
need to be more vulnerable etc etc
i i would love to hear chad's
perspective because i know that it's
changed from like day one or early weeks
of dating to now
where you know
it's why don't you open up more why
don't you talk about this more or this
and that or tell me what's going on
because chad is if you guys don't know
he runs business is a very successful
guy so
um i'd love to kind of hear his take on
on how he's maintained frame um
throughout this ltr
there's uh you know you would think um
over a long period of time there might
be some more
you know emotional talks and stuff like
that
but there's less
it's actually less i literally i'm like
this is how it's going to be this is
what's going on
this weekend is you know this weekend
we're going here or we make a plan or
whatever but as far as like
um
you know she'll ask me you know of
course i mean i've known her for four
years she'll ask me you know how's your
day stuff like that and i'll be like
awesome or you know well they went to
[ __ ] but i'm turning around and you know
by the end of the day the
the ship will be going in the direction
i wanted to go because
you know if it
if every day is perfect
i mean come on that's not reality
so i'm willing to say yeah my day was
shitty today but i got it turned around
no big deal how was your day you know
but
any emotion
in the relationship
is projected by her
i bring i i focus on bringing emotion
out of a woman any any girl that i've
ever that i date you know since i've
come into this space
six years ago
um i focus on the emotional connection
because like i like we had said before a
woman wants to be in a fairy tale they
want to be in a love story
and
you being the emotional tampon of that
arrangement
is not
a fairy tale for a woman
so for me it's
you know holding the frame being
masculine this is what i'm doing this is
where i'm going get on the ship it's
sailing with or without you kind of
thing
that has been through the whole
relationship
and any time i mean i literally pay
attention any time
that i've just had a bad day and i'm in
a bad mood or whatever
she completely changes her countenance
the way she acts the way she talks the
tone of her voice will change a woman
literally if she's in your frame
her whole entire emotional state will
change with your emotional state
changing
yeah so the more you can
yeah the more that you can be that rock
you're a [ __ ] mountain
nothing is going to move you you sh the
world could collapse you're gonna
rebuild it you still got this man
meteors coming to strike the earth yeah
don't worry about it i got this yeah
that's the thing yeah and so and it
because it's all about emotion
it there's no explanation there's no
logic there's no nothing it's all about
emotion and the emotional response you
bring out of a woman women are
um
initiating divorces like eight out of
ten times right and one of the biggest
precursors to a woman initiating a
divorce like being the one leaving the
relationship is she gets a a big raise
she gets a promotion and a big raise
any combination of those things because
women don't want to look across and down
at a guy they want to look across and up
at a guy they want to look up towards a
giant so
i always tell guys look you know the
clock is probably start starting to kick
like tick down to the end of the
relationship is it gonna end i don't
know maybe you got laid off or maybe you
had to take a uh lateral you know
position change in your job and you will
make more money in in six months and
she's a patient woman and she actually
digs your vibe and you know her making
10 or 15 000 more than you a year isn't
a huge deal for at that time but
you know female nature right like women
are hypergamous so they need to feel
like they have uh settled with their
best option
um on a consistent basis i mean if they
feel like they haven't settled with
their best option then again you know
don't be surprised if she leaves you at
some point that's that's just you know
on a bounce of probabilities how things
need to work so is that an important
part of managing frame in a relationship
yeah of course it is does anybody want
to chime in on that or have any personal
experience yeah i will
i do
that's my life every day all right um so
my woman has made more money than me for
since the day we met
and i think
everything rich says is
i mean goodness 99 of the time true
the way
i think
you can work around it is by being a
giant in your purpose
so
during
other conversations
you know i would say that my woman is is
relatively i don't know what the proper
phrase is red pillow where we'll say
she reads her own series of books
talking about the differences between
men and women and
and how that psychological structure
differs and she talks some of her
friends down off the ledge about it
and she will say flat out that one of
the things she found most attractive
about me was that her quote is the
people i answered to deferred to you
she says you absolutely own the space
every time you walk into the room
you're not a dick but you inspire
confidence in everybody around you the
topic of money
outside of anything other than joint
household finances has not one time come
up
i think as long as you are crushing your
purpose
as long as
like in my in my situation for example i
can make a lot more money the more time
i spend overseas so the compromise that
she knows she's making to have me around
and then also i choose so i can be
around my kids um is that i leave income
on the table she's more marketable
stateside
and
her knowing that i have you know i'm
internationally recognized in what i do
um
she's been around people who work with
and for me and seen the deference and
respect that i get because of that
capability i i it doesn't have to be a
death sentence i guess is what i'm
saying but you have got to manage
your own personal sense of confidence in
what you're doing you have to be a giant
and an expert at what you're doing and
then maximize it within those within
that that framework
perfect uh moth do you want to chime in
on that too i saw you not in your head
earlier i've got one two
okay well i think first we got to i mean
how old is this guy right i mean we get
age obviously comes into play comes in
as a definite factor i mean
if if you're in your early 20s and
you're in school to be a doctor or a
lawyer and she sees your potential for
later in life then typically not a big
deal now if you're 35 and doing that
same thing you decide that you're going
to stop you know flipping burgers and
decide you're going to go find your find
your purpose later in the life you're
you're pretty much done
um i i tend to think that
while
it can work in some situations and
i equate it to
like take height for example too right
short guys like okay level up in other
areas your woman makes more money than
you okay level up in other areas it just
means you have to work harder to sort of
maintain that frame i i tend to lean
towards you're better off um
staying away from those i mean if you're
already an ltr then then i get it uh
walking away may not be just the easy
choice
um
i i tend to try to avoid women or i
don't encourage men to go after women
that are making more money or on the
same level as them financially just
because it is extra work and it you do
have to
uh work harder
in an ltr i mean again it's going to
depend on your age well but i definitely
echo steve's point where as long as
you're buttoned up in other areas and
a lot of time it's the illusion of frame
too does he act as if right if you're
still
uh carrying on and you're still
maintaining the frame and your attitude
around her is not changing
i i think you're on the right track i
just think it takes a very high it's
it's an elevated level of frame and an
elevated level of game that most guys
are not going to be able to do
you